filmmakers today can bring just about
anything to life using state-of-the-art
digital effects whether it's exploding
space stations or giant transforming
robots if you can imagine it the movie
industry can spare a couple hundred
million to put it up on the big screen
but all that technology can also be used
for decidedly more mundane purposes like
making an actor's body parts look bigger
or erasing embarrassing tattoos in fact
the movie industry's top effects
animators are often hard at work adding
and subtracting tiny elements that may
never be noticed by most film goers
here's a look at some actors whose
real-life features had to be digitally
altered for the movies Dakota Johnson
whenever you see a nude scene in a movie
there's a good chance that nobody on set
ever really got naked often actors wear
flesh colored underwear and for most
movies this is enough because intimate
scenes don't really factor into the plot
not true for the film adaptation of
Fifty Shades of Grey those scenes are
the plot which posed a unique problem
for the effects department specifically
because it showed more skin than most
other films do a decision needed to be
made about whether or not Dakota
Johnson's character Anastasia Steele had
a personal grooming routine apparently
she didn't because a digital effects
artist had to go in during
post-production and use CGI to give
Johnson one of these cinematographer
Seamus McGarvey would later refer to
this as one of the most surreal moments
of his entire career closely followed by
overseeing the hiring process of a
suitable but double for Johnson Nicolas
Cage it's safe to say that Nicolas Cage
loves comic books his son kal-el is
named after Superman he changed his own
last name early in his career from
Coppola to cage is a nod to Marvel
character Luke Cage and he even has a
large tattoo of the Ghost Rider on his
arm
this latter tribute proved to be a
problem when cage was set to star in the
2007 Ghost Rider film because well it
would have been kind of weird for Johnny
Blaze to have a tattoo of his own
superhero alter ego on his bicep so the
decision was made to use the magic of
special effects to hide the offending
tattoo whenever cage needed to take off
it sure
a persistent rumor surrounding the movie
suggests that cages abs were also
created using the magic of CGI however
his ghostwriter co-star Ava Mendes has
confirmed they were in fact 100% real
[Music]
Christiaan Naren there's a scene in the
first season of Game of Thrones when the
character Hodor
played by actor Christian Naren gets
naked revealing the giant characters
suitably plus-sized Anatomy to achieve
the illusion Naren was asked to wear a
realistic-looking 16-inch prosthetic
that was attached to his groin using
blue so four weeks later I would be
finding pieces of prosthetic penis
attached to my own the effects
Department then blended the whole thing
to his body using digital effects
airbrushing out a special thong Naren
was wearing beneath the whole getup
according to the actor this thong
shielded his actual package from view so
well that one of his co-stars asked if
it was real there's only one response to
that question
otis paul rubens if you happen to catch
pee-wee's big holiday on netflix you may
have noticed that actor Paul Reubens
looked surprisingly spry and youthful
for a 60 something-year-old man to give
the impression that Rubens hadn't aged
since his last TV appearance as the
character CGI was used in tandem with
makeup lighting and sticky tape 2d aged
the actor and that last part isn't a
joke
tape was used to pull back Reubens face
for some scenes to make his skin look
smoother sometimes the simplest
solutions are the best ones to his
credit Rubens was surprisingly open
about the use of CGI to remove his
wrinkles admitting that peewee simply
wouldn't work with age mixed into it
French toast American toast the cast of
Glee the hit musical dramedy Glee
continued the long-standing Hollywood
tradition of hiring older actors to play
teenagers although none of the actors
playing high schoolers on the show were
the age they were supposed to be
they still apparently suffered from a
fairly common affliction that plagues
all young people acne this didn't sit
well with the producers who paid an
unnamed visual effects company to do
what was dubbed a pimple pass on most
episodes to ensure every actors skin was
blemish free because if there's anything
that's going to make a show relatable to
young people it's flawless looking
actors with perfect skin complaining
about being unattractive Jessica Alba
Jessica Alba resolved long ago did not
take off her clothes for a movie she
told Scarlett magazine in 2010 I can act
sexy and wear sexy clothes but I can't
go naked
my grandmother would freak out and throw
a towel over me if she saw me wearing
just a broad panties I can handle being
sexy with clothes on but not with him
off anyone who watched 2010's machete
after reading the article in Scarlett
was likely surprised when Alba appeared
to be nude during a shower scene but the
key word there is appeared in reality
Alba was clothed and her garments were
digitally replaced in post-production
with computer-generated skin Claire
Danes when a regular for a hit show gets
pregnant sometimes creators use the
tools the universe has given them and
write the pregnancy into the story but
when Claire Danes announced she was
pregnant with her first child in 2012
she assured fans her homeland character
Carrie Mathison would remain fervently
non pregnant for the show's second
season Danes on set worked for season
two of homeland continued as late as six
weeks before she gave birth her baby
bump was digitally erased in
post-production and body doubles were
also used to help with the subterfuge it
wouldn't be the last time homeland used
these strategies to keep a pregnancy out
of the story the following year they
used similar techniques on Morena
Baccarin even though it didn't show up
on screen Danes pregnancy didn't make
things any easier for her she described
one particularly difficult scene that
had her chained in a basement it was
four
I was seven and a half months pregnant
and I was like this she also said the
pregnancy made love scenes difficult
using the example of the shooting of one
love scene when her baby was
particularly active like he was
protesting on my husband's behalf Chris
Evans among all the otherworldly
characters in marvel movies the young
scrawny Steve Rogers in 2011's Captain
America the First Avenger remains one of
Marvel's most impressive CGI effects no
single technique was used to create the
smaller and skinnier pre experiment
Steve Rogers Marvel hired Lola visual
effects to do the digital body work on
Chris Evans for Captain America
Lola's supervisor Edson Williams told
variety that the so called Benjamin
Button method or digitally attaching
Evans's face to a body double was only
used for 15 percent of the shots for the
rest lola digitally shrunk Evans face
and body the process involved shooting
everything at least three times once
with Evans once with Evans smaller body
double and one clean shot without either
of them with each shot the team
determined whether to go the easier
Benjamin Button route for what Lola came
to call Steve slimming William said the
most challenging part of the process was
caused by Evans massive arms when shot
and profiled they blocked an entire
third of his body so the fabric of Evans
shirts would need to be digitally erased
and replaced with something else to give
the illusion of skinny and comparatively
weak arms that's probably the only time
in the history of superhero movies that
bulking up turned out to be a bad thing
guy Henry and ink ville de la for better
or worse freak wills are now a staple of
film franchises and CGI is part of what
makes them possible the filmmakers of
rogue one faced particularly tough
challenges for the story they wanted
they needed to recreate the characters
of Grand Moff Tarkin and Princess Leia
Peter Cushing who played Tarkin and
1977's Star Wars passed away in 1994
Carrie Fisher who portrayed Princess
Leia was still alive during the making
of rogue one but she looked and sounded
nothing like she had since about four
decades have passed so Tarkin and Leia
were digitally recreated for principal
photography
Tarkin was played by British actor Guy
Henry who wore a motion-capture
headpiece during filming animators
worked meticulously to recreate the
actors mannerisms not quite so much work
was needed for the digital rebirth of
Princess Leia when seen from behind
she's fully norwegian actress in build
gala from the front what you see is
almost entirely a digital creation
though Leia's outstretched hand is
Dallas Patrick Stewart and Ian McKellen
x-men The Last Stand is not a well-loved
movie among comic book fans but at least
one aspect of the film was pretty
groundbreaking the film opens with
Professor X and Magneto making an early
attempt to recruit Jean Grey into Xavier
school for mutants the flashback
sequence takes place around 20 years
before the events of the rest of the
film and the filmmaker is one of the
actors appearances to reflect those
younger days rather than using
prosthetics or special motion capture
suits the sequence was shot as if no
changes were going to be made to it at
all the VFX team then used a process
called digital skin grafting to
rejuvenate Stewart and McKellen
utilizing old photographs for reference
as well as consulting with a plastic
surgeon to learn the specifics of how
skin changes as people aged Kurt Russell
liked the film that preceded it
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 opens
unearthed several decades in the past we
see Meredith quill being romanced by a
Kurt Russell who looks like he could
have just finished filming Big Trouble
in Little China but there seems to be a
little disagreement regarding how this
on-screen rejuvenation was achieved when
Russell talked about the transformation
he said it was about 90% makeup and
added that the filmmakers didn't do much
digital manipulation Russell says he's
been working with the same makeup artist
Dennis Leger since 1989 and Ledger
pulled off most of the work we just did
a little brush-up clean-up on a couple
of things but it's pretty much what
Dennis Leonard dead writer / director
James Gunn's recollection is
significantly different in the comments
section of a video gun posted on
Facebook
the director responded to a fan question
about the flashback sequence
he wrote a company named Lola did the
effects and they did an incredible job
first we film every scene with Kurt a
young actor Aaron Schwartz watches
everything Kurt Russell does
he then goes in and mimics Kurt's
actions we then take Kurt's
acting in general face and body and
place Erin's skin on to him it is a long
painstaking process that took many many
months to accomplish Robert Downey jr.
for all the CGI used in Captain America
Civil War the film's most stunning
visual effect came in a comparatively
low key moment an early scene in civil
war opens to what appears to be a
flashback a young Tony Stark is giving
exactly the snark we expect from him as
his parents Howard and Maria are about
to leave from a fateful trip
who's the homeless person on the couch
this is why I love coming home for
Christmas right before you leave town we
eventually learned we're seeing Starks
memories as they're translated through a
device Stark has developed as they did
when digitally rejuvenating characters
in earlier films Marvel Studios called
on Lola visual effects to take 20 to 25
years off Downey the scene presented one
of the toughest challenges Lola has had
to tackle while working with Marvel
because the entire sequence was filmed
in a single shot
Trent Klaus Lola's visual effects
supervisor told The Hollywood Reporter
the shot was nearly 4000 frames long
with Tony Stark turning from one side to
the other multiple times physically
interacting with other actors and the
set itself and moving closer to the
camera for a very long uninterrupted
close-up klaus went on to say that
analyzing footage from Downey's late 80s
film work was essential in achieving the
effect and singled out 1987's less than
zero as a focal point but it's so real
it freaked me out
it's freedom you think I freak meat